oh what the oh that I sensitivity is so
high take my hero item oh well I invited
you you guys know my thing
no no now you're here hey enhanced
horror people are saying it's creepy
I'll do it but if they if I see myself
in a highlight reel in this game try to
advertise yourself I will sue record
that so I must shoe you mark is gonna be
the commercial for this game now you
don't play this game a box here for you
in the ground mark no your stereo this
box sure yeah open it see if you guys
get something out of it close your eyes
what does that do close your eyes
Zee closes your eyes oh god my eyes
what's wrong with my eyes
glass suit that's not good at all Blood
Club handbook stick together
no killing seriously no killing get
evidence
close your eyes only when to see the
shape that's right so there's a creature
around that we can't see unless our eyes
are closed whenever it spawns will know
by number how we'll know all right
all right let's do this wait powers
powers look at our power deck it looks
like I'm hacker
I've got nothing yeah oh wait mark click
on minor powers we have one point
available oh oh I have no slots
available
I have bandages but I have no slots I'm
gonna hold off yeah I don't think you
can actually buy one anyway so oh wait
you can get a major power do you have a
slot though yeah I think for the major
one I'm I am stronger than my peers
through these other people here a-holes
ignore them what a bunch of a-holes moly
look at this beautiful beverage Molly
brought me it's pink Wow
I have no idea what's happening let's do
it yeah I don't have any idea either so
let's just give this a try all right
guys take your time learn your powers
I'm gonna eat why literally we both we
already we would like to leave
all right dog did you guys look at the I
always see two missions here I see
Hoadley East and Hoadley West holding
Italy at the eastern end of red acres
most scenic neighborhood rests Hoadley
sleeps this cliff sort of look was named
after the historical suicide of a local
pastor although after the historic
suicide apparently how legendary was
suicide pretty legendary that's East
West says a series of family home stands
here nestled against the public park
ground maintained by chorus communities
and venting rumors of monsters in these
woods amused local children for years
perhaps because in truth this
neighborhood is rated among the safest
in Virginia so pastor suicide or the
safe virginia neighborhoods I've gotta
go with the safe Virginia neighborhood
you must be my gift of dance no how do
you do that no right right look at that
for several quick minutes right how do
you like that there's my gift of Neil
yep I know you like my gift of Neal this
is my gift of Neal to you hello prize
surprise oh I'm surprised I remain on my
knees in submission to your grace and
elegance alright so what how do we play
weight be sure to explain in great
detail what's the goal we're trying to
something collect it evidence usually
it'll tell us when we load in what our
specific goal is okay basically to go
around
usually stealthily collect evidence and
get out
evidence of what that guy's steal our
dream is mess with our heads bells said
they also take things from our rooms
like familiar personal stuff yeah take
something back steal the cryptogram
crypto what yeah what is our what is why
are we doing this Wade why mark we gotta
steal the cryptographic in the tutorial
that everyone skipped
our parents are like gone out somewhere
and we go out to explore and weird shits
going on all of the people in the
neighborhood are acting really weird and
there's like this shape that you have to
close your eyes to see and something is
causing like everyone to kind of lose
their minds and become like monster
zombies
I don't know if we knew the source of it
fully or what but we're trying to fight
back against whatever it is that's mind
controlling them red glowy thing good or
bad there's a flashbang and a tripwire
in this box do we need those ooh yeah I
disabled a speed trap I'm great at this
game I'm gonna take the flashbang I'm
last bang wait what there was stuff I
didn't get any stuff and this little
thing right here do you see this I
portal you know the monster can appear
there or teleport there or so well don't
touch it wait I don't remember exactly
how it triggers but once it does I feel
like those things are dangerous more
things happening what's with the void of
death why isn't the host that's been
lost what you're moving I see you oh no
you're looping oh no oh you're bad hey
whoa hi I think there's a secret over
here how do you turn on your light tea
for some reasons for telephone
tea for the light how do we interact
with this I don't remember in Iraq with
these things what you want to do is show
it your gift of dance oh you right click
to record it apparently okay is that a
is that a clue is that evidence I think
so yeah I don't know of what but it was
something different things will either
see or hear you so you've got your like
noise meter at the bottom if you crouch
with C make a lot less noise overall not
enough snacks for what guys that a light
just turned on in the house that's not
good that was I don't see any lights on
upstairs there's no lights on for your
lights on Oh light just came on
downstairs
I hear Rumble oh there's a person yeah
you see him do you see him I don't
remember if they can see or if they can
only hear I cannot remember
Oh lady what close your eyes footprints
those are my footprint what are the
footprints go I don't know the
footprints are inside the house is what
it looks like to me must be them walking
around is it my foot no it's my
footprints I'm seeing my own footprints
mark I can't go in there yeah I'm seeing
your footprints but I'm also seeing
something
shows up in mark oh it is oh my goodness
what do we know my god calm down I mean
I mean oh she's coming she's coming
she's coming between us I prank-called
her so now she's distracted by the phone
can we kill her or maybe at least you
have a crossbow right did I try to
zapper if you can I don't think it takes
your dumb permanently but it could stun
her temporarily I'm gonna try oh there
she is Kalman to zapper oh she's weird
oh I don't like her movement do not know
like Herman is concerning very
concerning I'm around the front of the
house right now oh I'm taking her down
oh my god I'm glad pin this pin mean am
I just standing on her what the what am
i doing mark killer how do I luckily now
what am i doing to this lady killer oh
there's killed her there's an upstairs
do you want take her outside and we can
lock her up well no I held her I killed
her
she's dead dead I stabbed her in the
brain with an arrow why did you shoot I
clicked
no listen it's fine I'm just gonna put
her in this closet it'll be fine dude
you killed her oh my god were murderers
we've words murders fine it's fine
look no one will find that's a computer
up here what mark not me that wasn't me
I groaned oh well I'm trying to lock the
front door and I actually just opened it
with the light on downstairs there's two
panels that lead to either a basement or
more more goddamn it looks like the
gateway to hell okay why am I not going
down I'm pressing down yeah I really
have to press forward to go down I guess
I'm looking I write in here so much I
know all right Bob you murderer just if
you see anybody shoot him in the head
Shh apparently I used my only arrow and
I could not extract it from her head so
I have no more arrows then she's
definitely dead right super dead super
dead I inserted my arrow all the way
what inside of her mrs. Johnson is dead
there's an elevator over here this
probably is quiet and not at all
insanely loud alright room for two I
there's room for all of us baby let's do
this four three two
oh wait this goes down we want you with
us on this one way and leave you trapped
in hell but apparently this goes deeper
deeper into hell well kiss your arse
dear our guardian your big big papa wait
here to save us wait he's fine it's fine
if I've seen this I've seen this same
things this you just you just can't run
in it I think it's a speed trap wait
there's a lot of noises well we're
closing on one of our objectives so I'm
sure it can't be any bad oh it's bad
there's a dude opening up a trap I put
it up he's not going towards the trap
I'm gonna I'm gonna prank column oh you
have the same ability I do yep
can we can we jump them I I can I think
I can let me let me all right I got him
pinned I don't know what it means when
they're pinned zap I guess nope you guys
explore this area real quick I'll just
I'll just keep him pinned okay junk cool
cool cool junk
what is this place yeah where where are
we man that tutorial really explains a
lot that I forgot I got a cryptogram
apparently yes we need that that's the
thing we need there's a flying robot Bob
you want to turn off I'll pin I'll pin
pin you ready yeah go for it whoops me
out daddy
okay first grab the signal keys we hit a
bunch to flashbangs over here is there
another guy there was the the camera was
coming back I got to Kryptos over there
so the green thing is the camera huh I
have no idea what that's not enough
snacks things means I'm guessing you can
trade snacks for bandages
there's someone else here how did you
miss Oh God coming coming coming okay he
just went away she he I'm gonna prank
caller I'm gonna prank caller and then
we can let's let's just keep exploring
wait this is really strange what like
just from my perspective the camera
there's a lot of like shuddering motions
and I'm directly behind and not it just
it doesn't feel right I'm just like guys
this just looks real bad hey guys I
found a door sleepwalkers I didn't
actually take care of his coming right
for me again you know that one the one
you only distracted the one that's
walking right for me okay he's my thing
that you need some sort of no no no
you're only really really really far
away from me you're the one who
volunteered for this you want me to come
back to give you a chance to grab a
crypto and then wave got them all and I
was like okay cool then we can move on
from here and then we didn't we didn't
then you guys moved on left me Bob I am
making a mess of this the shaper oh yeah
oh we gotta go you we gotta go we gotta
go was that gunfire
I was noise making I was distracting can
I let go of this guy probably let us get
past okay here we go
oh god what have I done what have I done
what have I done what have I done
get in the elevator oh my god close
close close [ __ ] close again let's go
alright they said the shape right I'm
not crazy
yeah it says close your eyes woodsy to
see the shape oh Jesus go hard that's my
fault guys I hope that thing's not here
already what would that mean if it was
here already that we'd have to deal with
an invisible creature great why is why
is across Bo Bob symbol although people
can't see at home because my beautiful
face is covering a bob bob has a symbol
over on what is that in the corner of my
eye what is going on in the corner of my
eye I don't know mark but you went a
different way that bob what has happened
I'm gonna go go go - Marco - Marco -
mark there's something if I went up
there something appeared in the corner
of my eye I will crouch you Psychopaths
well sunlight is it just a look at the
light was it the way the light looks no
no go up there and you'll see I don't
want to I see shapes wait I see shapes
and shadows
when I close my eyes yeah I don't see
anything the lights are definitely
different
oh it is the light okay it is the light
okay God but no no if I run up here
lalalala I know something in the corner
you guys I believe you Marc I believe
you I'm gonna open this door now I mean
you open this door now I didn't open it
I didn't open it I didn't know even in
you open I know I didn't press anything
to open I don't know you you've bumped
it then you boost you I don't think
that's how this game works I think it's
not just a house we went in no you're
not why would I was thinking we were
gonna do different why would it go the
same one no no we should do different
just be looked out for you know you mean
the lady in this house isn't dead yet
dork dork run flee it's fine it's fine
I've got this - yeah take it down zap Oh
God oh oh oh oh what'd you do Mar oh oh
oh oh oh nice the Condorcet got bonus
evidencing Oh mark wait the shape
anymore it's just a dude give me up I'm
up I'm getting go sleept no you can't
you can't it's possible the shape is
yeah oh you're you're getting shape
oh um oh you saved mark I see out never
mind
no I was not saved I was not saved um
mark why are you here or why are we both
kneeling we've been shaped um
Oh Oh why we're moving Oh mark yes mark
yeah are we going what are we doing do
you think I have control over this I
don't know help come help yeah we're
evil or something what what the hell
what'd you just do
oh wait can you uh go away all the shame
Thomas is my absence from the thing all
right thanks guys thank you thanks guys
we're definitely coming mark thanks guys
shaped bobbum shaped I got this I got
this
I so got this Bob I don't think you got
this this shape is coming from a uz to
see it shape guy yes I'm shoeplt
interesting bad thing that can happen
huh all right completion why am I the
super devil I don't understand you got
probably twice probably cuz you were
twice I'm the shapeless so I think the
more that we kind of [ __ ] up or interact
with things the more likely the shape is
to appear right to achieve and iron that
how's my shape good shape good shape I'm
gonna go to the cross place your body
what let a voice take over your body
permanently start over Mike whoa why
would you do that that doesn't sound
good
no one else won't try it I'm usually
like in the game it's pretty fun it's
it's pretty okay it's definitely intense
I got locksmith the power I think I got
an energy bar Oh No you guys ready dive
back in I feel like I know a lot more
about what's about to happen
me too what I got cheese sticks in me I
got cheese in me as well I love cheese I
love cheese it's so good even bad cheese
is good no the worst cheese is better
than the best vegetable TBC posters yeah
so we're in the same area
we have a different quest now it's not
just the parents teachers cups in a way
all they're pulling the strings the
holding town versus well us is this
legitimate like ours it's just like you
know kids next door Imaginationland
I hope it's kids next door
Imaginationland because this is this
scary
this bold Oh whose decorations are
blood-red I love it oh my god that's not
good that's gnarly
what are you plural playing the
fourteen-year-old kid dude gnarly gnarly
so I'm pretty sure they're all sound
activated right because they looked
right at it didn't really do anything
yeah they have like eye blindfold covers
on eye blindfolds you know yeah I mean
oh God I mean oh really
he's coming downstairs anyway oh [ __ ]
jump up Bob coming in coming after you
coming after you is there anything in
the houses that we would want coming
after me coming after me I am okay
ground I am under ground come back down
wait coming back down coming back down
oh I found a hole entrance do you guys
want to go down it well if you'd like
lose all the posters are up here but
there could be bonus evidence and again
items and stuff down there oh I'll take
a gander or I won't because the
directional and ladders really sucks I'm
go for it
that's just two of the elevator there's
a ladder over this way wait there's wait
huh did you go over this way no where
are you
there's footsteps to this ladder in
front of me what does that mean is that
good I don't know wait shape should not
be out yet
look look down this path to your left
you see footsteps going over there to
the ladder yes if you close your eyes
yeah and then up the letter - yeah
should we check that out or should we do
the opposite of that probably the
opposite boot you know let's do it let's
do it I'm ready all right cool you guys
gone I got I'm near a upholster get it
mark how do you know you're near a
poster you can [ __ ] oh it's the
objectives so just above why am i making
so much I got two posters and the other
ones 13 meters away oh there's a lot of
people outside
okay last posters I'm near you guys why
are they out in the middle of the night
what are the weird red teenies what does
that mean this place fun house exterior
okay I see a little targeting there's a
oh yeah you got that mark I got this
watch from a safe distance okay cool
well you're a pincher upstairs and take
a peek
I'm gonna go to this one over here I see
this yeah you got a problem help how can
I help how how would I
oh man do the poster rod lead them away
no no do you have a poster can you do it
have a poster okay so I gotta do it
wait chill out chill out there's one
right next to you man calm down wait go
do that go do the poster over at the
next house yeah you got that I'll make
sure you're covered they're just all of
the middle of the street
oh they're pissed oh they're pissed why
are they so pissed um that might be
partially my fault oh god I hate this
wait we got to go let's do not worry
anymore
they're just they're everywhere mark
you've got three posters on you so I
guess you got to place them I see three
spots they're all in this house there's
two on the outside one on the inside of
this house what what is the point of
these posters they don't even make any
sense it seems to really piss off the
sleeping people so I don't know man I
don't know advertisements wait inside
this house is the last one there's just
another on the outside it's inside yeah
right right here to the left huh oh wait
where'd it go no well we got it it's
it's on the next house it's not the
house sure here's to sir I was wrong I
was wrong I don't know that much bonus
evidence on the videos care about the
bonus evidence or not I just want a
complete a mission I'd like to get
mission one under the under under our
pants oh it's over here wait
just put it on there no that was one
coming there's one coming careful not
fast enough it's not he closed the gate
what an a-hole pick up some instrument
dampeners what does that even mean
what instrument it's like a drum and
mute what are they talking about wait
those posters show up when you close
your eyes what do they say
join GBC join TBC join TBC crisix our
should snuggles are we putting out are
we the baddies maybe I don't know that's
a good question
wait what have you gotten us into all
right mark so you're going that way for
those bad boys yeah yeah for these bad
boys who should I go with I don't know
can mark make crank calls if not you
might want to go with him I cannot okay
I will go your way mark I'm gonna go out
to the street what the hell I'll come
with you so I can crank call got it you
gotta be cool when you make crank calls
I already learned my lesson Bob hey man
oh here's another shape hole man there's
a lot of shape holes this neighborhood
seems to be custom built for shapes I
know the shape guy really it really got
them onside before they did the
construction like the cranberry man
getting into everything that light
sounds like Satan I do not hear what
just happens what's going on with my eye
it hears oh I had that happen to beyond
the door we wait it hears god oh no no
beyond the door
we will wait what steps leading from
myself in a direction no they're gone
now no do you see those yeah I see those
I'm following footsteps I don't know if
we're supposed to do that why would God
not yours child but soon I am following
the footsteps I don't like don't like
don't like to like house [ __ ] here Bob
come get a sound dampener give one to
Daddy
that's not how that's not what you want
to do there's another one in this house
[Music]
you know there might be I'm gonna close
the door I'm gonna close the door and I
join you yeah yeah how's it going way
doing good it sounds great
is that good
Oh your desk the shade oh god I don't -
wanted to escape what is this what
happened
something new got me I've not seen
before good it's dragging me away what
do i do what do i do what do i do we're
really far away from you with oh the
little minion will be ours
it knows minion the little minion will
be ours it knows wait that's not good
can they hear me Oh mark I think we need
to go slightly faster is this like a
situation where the developers are
talking to us you know what I mean well
that's why it's suppose it's it's creepy
right that's not good did you not see
the thing that just happened there's no
one near me with the flashlight it's not
you - you didn't see the bright flash of
colors and sounds and your vision you
didn't see no no I'm totally fine I
think we just need to get the sound
damper that way this camera isn't that
my one abilities turn off camera that's
alive wait yeah I'm alive just I use a
bandage er there's a lady there hey lady
damn it this person took away my
dampener I'm gonna go back well I'm
gonna go get the damper then oh it's
marked you see the person with the
flashlight oh good nice and now I can
see the targets they're all underground
yeah so we have to go down into the maze
now okay so we need to get into a house
it's not this one okay alright wait get
out of light for shit's sake getting in
the light is what pisses them off
alright so we need to go into a basement
get down into the Oh did you just make a
bunch of noise I accidentally jumped and
I did not mean to you know after
everything I've done I guess I can't
really fault you join us below little
skirm okay it's the developers no no I
can't
nah a little
little skirt that sounds just like the
worst kind of thing yeah that's horrible
that's what the handkerchief right there
that's what you'd call the the the juice
you get out of the handkerchief at the
end of the day that's your soup there's
a box in here there's a box in here it's
lockpick and tranq Dart
well I'll take the tranq dart since I
have the thingy the tracer it's still
there back in the house no I took the
tranq dart I got to oh can we all grab
both of these marks there might still be
two things in there mm-hmm
can can each of us grab the things
apparently I don't remember that being a
thing before maybe it was I like your
strategy mark thank you let's be sneaky
thank you
oh there's a guy way over there that we
just came from in the yard then we can
use this to get on the roof we just got
to get downstairs right so one of these
oh my god what was that oh oh oh my god
I tranked him you tranq the shame he
only fell down for like half a second ah
get away get away and be sneaky get away
and be sneaky I tranqued him and he fell
down I think he lost rabbit right right
right
sinners angel will find he's coming he's
coming he's coming he's coming he's
coming for me
okay all right he lost me he's bet he's
in that backyard we need to get away
from here mm-hmm I left my I left my
very important item there you know what
if you could just be quiet for a minute
and stop doing stuff all right he's
still looking for me this guy is
beelining straight for you good cause I
was in I was an eyes closed mode the
shape that she's coming for you guys the
shape is coming for you guys he's out on
the street I'm sure he's right next to
you are you coming for him oh yeah he's
coming no he's not he's going away he's
going away no one ever goes for me
apparently Baba apparently I'm in the
clear I'm just gonna casually go sister
a little house casually follow you my
safe here I was high are you hanging on
your stupid your gets you you're an
actual [ __ ] and I hope he grabbed your
dumb ass off of there yeah oh man look
at holy jeez shall it be minion first
yes oh very fair
oh that's wave you got a yes I see that
yeah I see that oh my god no way come on
man I've been grabbed
where are you worried were you grabbed
oh I'm okay he just grabbed yeah well
all he did was grab me I'm getting in
this house I'm gonna find it down I
don't care I'm in here's a down I found
it down I'm gonna come to you Marv come
to me there's a down here I'll distract
it or some [ __ ] oh no all right did you
this is the house yeah yeah there's a
down right near me in the room I got it
oh my god this is the worst dick move
dick move dick move how it screams we
have just begun funny I'm coming down
your hole mark looks like they're man it
does not like you whatever it is for you
fella purrs they have absolutely picked
up on how much I see a little bit yeah
oh yeah okay wait just take it like a
champ and uh over over on the ledge
there is a chest what do we got we got
firecrackers in another tranq Dart
nice come get it I think if it's what do
you think it is they offer you to us
minion yeah I take him
he really is juicy I'm not that juicy
who's that whoa whoa whoa how come
I'm not that juicy I tranqued it good
good try to drink good drink the thing
is here don't go breaking my heart
you don't know that it's here it's
definitely here guys I'd like bleeding
out can we go can we wrap this up yeah
yeah yeah yeah just I got it's all this
dampener install the dampener okay okay
okay I stalled I got one dampener hey
guys I've got three dampeners on me is
that a problem that's probably not great
we're I think it's okay that was the
only one I had on me okay - way to
install some dampeners yeah come on man
let's do the let's do the dampener thing
come on mark how do we get rid of camera
I think we just gotta dodge it it seems
to watch everywhere we might want to go
no no no oh okay there we go um where's
the dampener thing right on the other
side of all oh can it see us it's for
you oh that's only to you we're not even
seeing that yeah we're not seeing that
what wait you're doing great keep it up
man broke my ankles are you supposed to
break their ankles they don't deserve
you I know Wayne come on hurry we need
your you need to install one we've only
got three total oh listen man I'm trying
to find it but I just keep bad things
keep happening to me it's on your screen
are you on Laverne Shirley yeah do we
know the name the shape is it named the
ship wait no don't say the name I don't
know what the name is what's the name I
don't know any names what do you expect
us to do just put a dampener in man
what's what's your deal do you have the
last dampeners shape Watts me the shape
wants my soul wait this shape is near me
yeah no no of our sins what did we do we
didn't do anything oh hey Mark yeah he's
coming for me you're a fine man you got
this I'm gonna go up here there's some
nice stuff oh no you know what you have
done
did somebody just make me make a crank
call I'm shoeplt hey stop running wait
oh yeah wait what are you sprinting away
what is this I'm not homeless not
intentionally oh [ __ ] I felt I felt I
felt I felt one following you mark
there's a hotel I can tell I can tell I
can tell
alright see ya dude I'm gonna go to this
cave where oh you guys are both got I
can't see any dampers there there's some
over by me I don't know where weights
went okay I picked these up but says you
have three yeah I scream I hear noises
near me you might be in trouble mark
yeah oh yeah definitely I think all I
gotta do is just run cuz I don't think
there's anything else I could do at this
point but I seem to be running away from
got back oh yeah I forgot I can get you
guys back right yeah that's why I
thought you were going after me earlier
no god no it's fine it's fine it's fine
here we go no it's fine it's fine
come here you bastard just dear look at
me in the eye that's not good that's not
good I'm one I'm dead again I don't know
I can't really exist yeah yeah I've know
whatever do that do this how do we get
up there what the hell we speak as blood
we speak as one what the hell how do i
there's no way up there what is this
garbage so you have to go all the way
back the way you got into this room what
what what oh my god
Oh mark oh whatever
[Music]
well Bob you got this okay I got fine
I hear horrible noises around you yeah
yeah yeah I'm concerned I'm concerned
you know wiped out why would that be I
don't I don't feel good
hmm about my chances mmm hmm hmm
do tell you know what I think they may
have found me perspective where I was
watching with my eyes closed
no I couldn't see your eyes closed I was
watching them I'm the angel what does
that mean I don't know what do you hover
over three objectives complete Jesus
[Music]